bonjour à tous Nous sommes au Salon
International de l'Agriculture pour nous
échangeons sur la souveraineté
alimentaire sur l'avenir de notre
agriculture française et européenne en
tant que vice-président de la Commission
du commerce international au Parlement
européen je suis bien sur interpellé sur
l'accord de commerce entre l'Union
européenne et les pays du Mercosur
Brésil Argentine Uruguay Paraguay
l'Union européenne souhaite relancer cet
accord le président de la République la
redit en venant au salon la France
continuera de s'opposer à cet accord
tant qu'il ne tient pas en compte mais
considérations environnementale et de
concurrence déloyale c'est la position
que j'ai défendu aussi au Parlement
européen quand nous avons fait adopter
cet amendement pas de Mercosur en l'état
parce que nous ne pouvons pas demander à
nos agriculteurs de faire des efforts de
plus en plus considérable que ça soit
avec nos adjectifs du pacte vert que ça
soit sur toutes les questions
environnementales sanitaires et pour
autant
importer des produits qui nous
respectent pas ces normes il nous faut
de la cohérence c'est pourquoi nous
continuerons de dire à la Commission
européenne que cet accord n'est pas
acceptable en l'état